[Musique]
est-ce que vous connaissiez un peu
l'histoire du château avant de voir les
spectacles la région bah oui mais non
personne m'avait raconté l'histoire
semble intéresser ah oui beaucoup
qu'est ce qui vous a plu surtout surtout
les les lumières là bas le décor
beaucoup de l'école
l'histoire aussi que ce qu'on connaît
pas l'histoire de notre pays est ce que
ça a changé la vie de la commune ce
spectacle je pense que oui parce que
vous avez beaucoup de gens qui ne qu'une
part ne serait pas trop est clos comment
orienter certains l'asie certaines
certains week-ends par exemple quand on
a appris qu'il y allait se passer
un spectacle au puy du fou vous avez
déjà qu'on dit ah ben ça c'est chouette
leur amour va pouvoir qui participent et
moi la première j'avoue que ce qui me
concerne j'étais tout de suite
subjugué par cette rue clergé m'a
demandé tout de suite dit oui puis non
mais c'est parfait dès le mois de mai
lorsque philippe de villiers un jeune
énarque et prix de la vendée et les
villageois de 11 communes ont commencé
ensemble des préparatifs de cette
résurrection
le château du puy du fou a perdu sa
tranquillité ensommeillés leur
tranquillité les 12 cents participants
ont perdu en même temps au nom de ce
plaisir bien particulier qui annonce le
spectacle le soir lorsque tout
s'assombrit puis silini il faut voir
dans quelles conditions on a eu les
répétitions cet hiver les répétitions
qui ont commencé à partir du 1er mai on
a toujours travaillé dans la boue sous
la pluie
et je pense à tous ces figurants qui
venait de faire leur journée de travail
philippe de villiers nous disait que
leur disait quelquefois on va arrêter
mais il voulait continuer à faire leur
répétition même sous la pluie dans les
villages y avait une une chaude amitié
tout le monde ça mais bien on rigole un
bon coup on se retrouvait à toutes les
répétitions et puis alors chacun disons
le se croyait pas un petit artiste
devant un succès pareil quand on pense
que toutes les laisser en jeu nous donne
cinq à six mille spectateurs
c'est plein à craquer ça marche trop
bien puisque les spectateurs ne sont pas
très contents pour une partie d'entre
eux en tout cas puisque nous ne pouvons
pas leur refuser l'accès au spectacle
étant donné qu'il n'y a que 19 séances
et d'un autre côté nous ne voulons pas
leur promettre à tous du moins d'être
assis confortablement puisque la moitié
les spectateurs chaque séance
la moitié des 6000 spectateurs puisque
c'est à peu près la moyenne que nous
faisons sont assis sur l'herbe dans les
conditions qui ne leur permettent pas de
bien voir le spectacle et certains
d'entre eux sont pleines nous nous en
excusons mais ça n'est pas possible nous
sommes débordés par rapport à tout ce
que nous pouvions espérer au départ pour
début on savait pas dans quelle banque l
ar pont ce qu'on se mettait évidemment
on pensait que c'était
une petite affaire alors que maintenant
certainement pris l'important c'est
évidemment on est très heureux du succès
de cette entreprise mais enfin encore
que le mon entreprise est mal choisi ils
ont qu'on est débordé est-ce que vous
avez vu vous ce sentiment un moment dont
on parlait tout à l'heure du sentiment
de ras-le-bol
oui oui parce que vraiment on était
submergé il nous demandait pas mal de
choses à faire mais toujours on le
faisait et sans dégoût on avait vraiment
envie de le faire via c'était la fatigue
arriver
et puis tout à coup bon alors les
spectacles commands et puis le public
vient vous avez été un peu un peu
surpris du succès oui et c'est ces
succès qui nous a aidés à continuer tout
de suite on a vu que c'était bon tout le
monde a senti qu'il fallait continuer et
c'est ça qui a fait marcher tous ceux
qui travaillent bénévolement dans
l'ombre parce que il ya les figurants
mais il ya sûrement autant de personnes
du travail nombre phénomène nouveau dans
un spectacle c'est ce qui a permis de
réunir des gens de communes différentes
qui non seulement ne se parlaient pas
mais qui parfois été en état de
d'hostilité les uns avec les autres
puisqu'il y avait un esprit de un esprit
de clocher assez extraordinaire entre
les communes environnantes
alors que maintenant toutes ces communes
et tous ces gens vont main dans la main
ils se retrouvent tous les vendredis et
samedis soir la grande fête au puy du
fou
[Musique]